[Musique]
c'est trop beau tu as vu les nuages là
qui sont vraiment rouges super puissant
[Musique]
là je demande si on voit encore le
soleil aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il est déjà trop bas
au-dessous de
l'horizon on va voir on va guêterce que
siil sort il va sortir juste
là mais normalement d'ici quelques jours
c'est officiellement le début de la nuit
polaire donc là on est vraiment la
frontière jour
[Musique]
nuit mais tu comprends ce que je te dis
avec ces lumières ces fameuses lumières
du mois d'octobre
ça tu vois ça si je le vois pas dans
l'année j'ai un besoin physique tu vois
de voir
ça il a rien de plus beau
quoi là tu arrives à voir qui se dessine
tout au fond du
fiord ce que je préfère ça c'est un des
plus gros glaciers qu'on a dans la
région et on devrait sen rapprocher dans
les prochaines heures
[Musique]
donc
donc là on est en train de se rapprocher
de ce glacier de fou quoi qui s'appelle
Nord SHB je pense que c'est un de mes
glaciers préférés
aubn j' reviens pas à quel point on
s'approche
regarde-moi toutes ces crevasses quoi
c'est un des glaciers qui est les plus
crevassés par
ici tu as vraiment l'impression de voir
les entrailles du
[Musique]
glacier et c'est fou c'est que le
glacier change ultra rapidement ici
comme tu le
sais chaque année en fait il est
différent là cette grotte de glace elle
y était pas il y a quelques mois à
peine
ah c'est trop
beau mais tu vois tous ces glaciers là
qui se rapprochent de l'océan c'est les
glaciers qui se retire aussi le plus
rapidement ici au sebalbar parce que
l'océan se réchauffe vachement aussi
bien sûr températur de l'air mais toute
cette glace qui est encore en contact
avec l'eau c'est vraiment la glace qui
fond le plus rapidement et qui se retire
qui remonte en fait sur terre et là tu
vois ça une sorte de mécanisme de
protection du glacier quoi qui recule
recule recule une fois qu'il est sur
terre il font un petit peu moins
rapidement
là c'est tellement beau d'avoir cette
petite couche de neige qui vraiment met
les reliefs en valeur c'est somptueux
quoi et tu vois souvent la près de ces
grottes il y a plein d'oiseaux on les
voit ils sont tout petits assez
lointains mais c'est parce Queau frond
des glaciers tu une sorte de contraste
entre l'eau douce du glacier et l'eau
salée de l'océan et toutes les petites
crevettes t les petits organism qui eux
aiment l'eau salée se retrouve tout d'un
coup baigné dans l'eau douce ne
comprennent pas ce qui se passe
remontent à la surface et les oiseaux
vont les
becter on dirait du marbre presque c'est
fou je crois que le bleu de la glace
c'est quelque chose qui nous hynotise
tous c'est une grande partie de la
raison pour laquelle je suis devenue
glacier c'est voir des trucs comme ça
quo c'est vraiment rare en tout cas de
pouvoir voir La La La toute base du
glacier la raison pour laquelle la glace
est tout aussi bleue c'est parce que la
glace qui est à la base elle est
tellement écrasée sous le poids de la
glace auus
que toutes les petites bulles d'air qui
sont prises au piège dans la glace se
sont échappé en fait sous la pression et
plus il y a de bulle d'air plus la glace
elle a l'air blanche et moins il y a de
bullle d'air plus elle est bleue et le
bleu c'est la seule couleur qui est en
fait qui ne passe pas au travers de la
glace qui est rebondi en quelque sorte
et c'est pour ça qu'on voit par nos yeux
que la glace est
bleue oh là
là c'est fou quoi et là c'est sûrement
un endroit qui est très actif on a ce
qu'on appelle ces fameux vellages
d'iceberg donc là où la glace se casse
tombe dans l'océan et forme tous ces
iceberg qui contribue à l'augmentation
du niveau des
océans ah il est magnifique hein mais je
vois plein de signes de la fondte quoi
qui a eu lieu cet été ça a été un été
juste désastreux ici pour les glaciers
valba en fait chaque été est pire que
l'été
précédent
et et là les glaciers ont perdu vraiment
une une un énorme volume de glace ces
derniers mois donc là même si c'est très
beau en fait je peux pas m'empêcher de
remarquer tous ces petits signes qui
nous montre que bah voilà le glacier
c'est vraiment aminci il a perdu
beaucoup d'épaisseur on voyait pas du
tout autant de roches l'année dernière
euh et le problème c'est que c'est un
vrai cercle vicieux qui se met en place
ici c'est que tu vois déjà le glacier il
est en contact avec l'océan et l'océan
se réchauffe de façon catastrophique ici
dans
l'Arctique mais aussi toutes ces roches
plus il y a de roches exposé autour du
glacier plus ces roches en magasine la
chaleur du soleil et plus le glacier se
retire et et là tu vois en fait c'est
des lambeau quoi ce qui reste
[Musique]
ici
is même si ça reste un monstre de glace
tu te rends compte que ils sont hyper
fragiles hyper sensibles à ce qui se
passe ah petit oiseau finalement C glaci
contribu directement à tout un
écosystème ici quoi c'est pas que
important pour les glaciologues c'est
[Musique]
sûr mais c'est magique tu vois qu'il a
quand même un cor de l'énergie glacier
il a un cor franchement il se bat le
fait qu'il soit crevassé ça nous montre
qu' a encore énormément de glace qui
pousse quoi qui essaie de de bouger
toute cette masse en direction de
l'océan donc il en a encore sous le pied
nn SH il est connecté à une énorme
calotte juste derrière ici les montagnes
donc il a de la chance il a encore
encore pas mal de de décennies devant
lui mais mais là tu vois là en partie
basse là tout montre que le glacier est
en train de subir un changement
climatique
catastrophique
je sais pas si tu arrives à voir mais on
arrive on voit C ces veines ces lignes
dans la
glace et en fait chaque ligne c'est une
année d'accumulation neige sur le
glacier c'est un peu comme les cernes
d'un
arbre en fait tu peux si on faisait
comme il faut tu peux compter le nombre
de de ces
lignes pour reconstruire l'âge du
glacier et donc là on est en face
d'un sacré vieillard quand même cette
glace elle a facilement plusieurs
centaines
d'années et tout ça qu toute cette
mémoir on est en train de la voir
disparaître sous nos yeux mais il a
toujours un aspect de fou quoi quand tu
regardes ces glaciers c'est que pour moi
c'est vraiment la pureté absolue quoi il
y a pas plus beau je trouve sur terre du
moin dans l'Arctique des glaciers
pareils mais tu sais que s'il y a un
morceau de glace qui se décroche
franchement on est tellement proche on
est mort là et donc il y a toujours ce
contraste o tu dis ah ouais c'est super
beau quoi et en même temps tu sais que
c'est deadly quoi des paysages comme
ça ils sert toujours beaucoup beaucoup
plus fort que
toi si tout le monde pouvait voir ça
quoi sur terre tu
imagines je pense que si les gens
avaient l'occasion de voir ça de sentir
l'air qui vient des glaciers de tu as
vraiment l'impression de sentir le pou
du glacier quoi je suis sûre qu'on
s'intéresserait beaucoup plus à ce qui
se passe ici et déjà qu'on comprendrait
leur force c'est quand tu vois ça quoi
et ça c'est un glacier parmi des
centaines de milliers d'autres quand tu
vois ça que tu comprends la force du
truc quoi et c'est ça que j'essaie de
partager quoi c'est de montrer déjà à
quel point c'est beau c'est magnifique
ces monstres de
glace mais à quel point malgré leur
beauté
malgré le fait qu'il soit gigantesque
c'est ultra fragile qu un glacier il y a
besoin de peu de choses pour que toute
cette glace la
parte et tout ça ça contribu à
l'élévation du niveau des
océans en plein été tu imagines des
températures assez hautes énormément
d'eau qui Rui celle du glacier et sans
arrêt sans arrêt tuas des villages donc
des morceaux de glace qui se décrochent
du fond du glacier tu as l'impression
d'être dans un un TER é quoi tu as
l'impression que c'est la guerre
tellement que le glacier il est actif
tellement qu'il est vivant et tellement
qu'il fond
rapidement et maintenant la CL arrive
tout se calme un petit
peu mais tu vois là toutes ces petites
îles tu vois toutes les roches là qu'on
a juste à côté de nous quelques années
c'était sous la glace quoi C
complètement sous la
glace
ah mais là tu vois même le trou là-haut
n'y était pas quoi ça y était pas il y a
quelques
mois et là tu le glacier il est en train
de se faire attaquer de partout quoi de
partout et ce qui me touche c'est que ce
glacier ça fait super longtemps que je
le connais je crois que c'était en
2008 la première fois où je suis allé
sur le glacier c'est le premier glacier
que j'ai étudié au zalbarn à l'époque
j'étais étudiante en licence donc je
commençais vraiment mes études en
glaciologie et on nous avait fait camper
juste là sur la gauche pendant une
quinzaine de jours et je me souviens
avec mes profs marchai au milieu des
crevasses on était même pas encore D C
je me souviens même plus si on avait des
crampons et les profs nous disaient
juste évitez de tomber dans les
crevasses quand même ce serait sympa et
à l'époque je pense qu'on se rendait pas
du tout compte quoi à quel point le
glacier était dangereux et maintenant
c'est plus autorisé maintenant ils le
font plus comme ça à l'université mais
mais ouais ça fait longtemps que je le
croise ce glacier quoi et ça me désole
en tout cas de voir l'état dans lequel
il est
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tu as l'impression d'avoir
des écailles de dragon non qui caresse
les
[Musique]
rochers je suis tellement contente qu'on
ces
[Musique]
couleurs
thank you so much for being here I must
say it's always an absolute joy to be
back at Unis so my name is Heidi
syvestra my background is in biology and
let me tell you I've spent quite a bit
of time sitting in this room whether it
was as a bachelor student and then as a
PhD student in the department of geology
and it's truly during my time here at
Unis that I got to learn this art of
outreach and every single one of here is
at the right place at the right time you
must understand that by being here in
one of the fastest warming environments
on earth you have great power you get to
spend time in the field you get to
witness incredible changes from one year
to the next you get to collect the data
to synthesize it for the scientific
community but obviously with this great
power of knowledge es great respibility
and today my is about the duty that we
have as experts to communicate on what
we see in the field to communicate on
what we learn on what we understand and
to tell the whole world about what's
taking place in the Arctic because
what's happening here in isviously
affecting the rest of the world and this
has l me to create a project that took
place last which was called climate
sentinels we Tred to completely change
the way we do science in the Arctic
first of all we created a team of female
scientists we also connected with
schools around the world from Canada to
Australia France the
US and then most importantly we showed
that even in the most extreme environ we
can try to reduce our carbon footprint
as much as possiblevly here
many option when
itesintly connected to the way we
theield and the only option we were
facing was to ski pingka for a month
Sking from
to and this is what we did for 32 days
and I can tell you I'm still totally
broken from the expedition was hard weed
to show that we can do we can
even
of we col s samples over 450 K to better
understand the deposition of black
carbon on the snow here in zban as you
know pollution from further south is
coming all the way here changing the
albido of these environments making them
melt even faster and today our samples
are at western Washington University and
they will help us understand where is
the pollu coming from but also what has
burnt in the first place and this really
help us to pinpoint those areas in the
world that are affecting the most of the
snow and ice here
in and this expedition by far was the
hardest thing I've ever done and we
didn't take pictures when the conditions
were really horrible but they were
really horrible i don't know if some of
you were here in April last year but it
was lerally one
after the other after the other after
the other we never saw the end of this
every day we ris losing t or camp we had
to dig HES in the snow to be able to
avoid being evacuated
by and this helped us to continue and to
successfully complete the
expedition what we faced day and out
was
ofateange what scientists have been
saying for decades and decades that with
every increasing degree what we get in
is higher temperatures wet conditions
but also completely unpredictable
weather
systems it was crazy for us to see this
I mean I've been coming to zvat since
2008 I lived here for four years I had
never seen anything like this before and
I can tell you that we came back from
this expedition with such a rage to tell
the world about what we had faced to
tell the world about the fact that
what's happening up here in the Arctic
is truly affecting the rest of the world
i'm sure all of you guys are on LinkedIn
on facebook on snapchat on twitter
whatever Instagram TikTok all of you
have the tools available to make this
science accessible to as many people as
possible it is our duty
as people who the privil to here to
communicate on
thesesu and so as soon as we came back
from the expedition the first night I
was back in town I was speaking to
policy makers in France about what we
had experienced and I starteding tons
and tons of messages about this
expedition and still to this day almost
every day I get messages from kids
aroundingimate
change and few got these weird messages
on Instagram that was back in
2019 I checked my Instagram and I
started to see these messages from an
organization called cumbles blancas
Colombia i'm like what is this so I
start reading the messages and it says
dear Heidi it would be great to have you
here and to visit our melting glaci we
have so much to learn about the tropical
glaciers and sadly these glaciers will
not exist in the next 30
sobres blancas Colombia are this
incredible bunch of people that are
moving mountains in their country
they're not scientists they are some of
these youngsters influencers artists
they work with indigenous communities
and they have realized that there are
glaers in that country and they will do
whatever it takes to help preserve these
glciers for as long as
possible and five months after receiving
this message there I was in a smoky tent
for a day and half a night speaking to
these indigenous communities to get
permission to go and study the glaciers
of Colombia they have 70 tiny glaciers
that are called tropical glaciers they
are stradling the equator and they are
fighting how to survive but today sadly
there's nothing we can do to save these
tropical glaciers there's nothing we can
do to prevent them from totally
disapparing the temperature threshold is
1 de Celsus if we go above that these GL
will disappear and as you know we're
already way above plus one
de the water goes into these crazy
ecosystems called PAM the PAM are full
of endemic species and this is a drone
image looking down the param are these
wetlands that are acting like natural
sponges
they get the water from the glaciers and
release the water throughout the year
and eventually the water goes down the
valley and these glaciers can have an
influence over tens of kilometers even
hundreds of kilometers from where they
are found and these glazes help support
entire economies in
Colombia this is where the coffee places
are this is where coffee is growing so
this is why today these glaciers still
matter so very much and we need to tell
the whole world about these tropical
glaciers because if these glaers
disappear what's coming next next will
be the glaes of the Himalayas next will
be the glaes of Patagonia the glaers of
Alaska and all of these glaers still
matter so very much today it is crucial
that you understand the duty we have as
people who ro around the field here in
spbs as people who
sence as people who are a to syes the
sence because if not us who will who
will tell the policy makers about those
environments who will tell the private
sector about what taking place here in
the Arctic who will tell your parents
your friends who will tell your circle
of influence about these changes well no
one will this is very C do not any el
to share your science to make your
science moreessible and today we have
absolutely zero time left to start the
fight against climate change and you all
aware of it here in this room so it's
really high time that you speak up that
you speak out and I really hope to be
able to count on every single one of you
thank you very
much
a lot of folks made up their minds
thatimate ch is not real and
yet like as someone doing outreach as
someone doing science education you
still have to try and get through to
them how how do you do that I conducted
an experiment a couple of years
ago I mean I don't know if it was a good
one or not eventually I got toally
banned frombook because of this so I did
is that IED to learn more about these
people I want I really wanted to get in
their heads and understand but why do
people believe that the earth is flat
why do people believe that climate is
not warming or that CO2 cannot affect
temperatures on earth so in in France I
joined two pages two groups on Facebook
and these groups were called um climate
realists so because they know what's
happening we don't but i genuinely
really um join them with a very good
heart and and I was like I really want
to understand how you are how you can
live today as an adult and trying to
fight you know the signcis from the IPCC
from NASA from Isa how can you live with
that today and so for two years I was on
these pages they had so much knowledge
about science and about climate change
it was insane and so it it really forced
me to be so much better at knowing the
basics and eventually they started to
share stuff about glaciers and and Ies
and I was like okay I couldn't I
couldn't stay quiet so I started to
interact with them i've always St
extremely polite and this is very
important otherwise for sure you get
blocked right away um but I really
learned that that basically these people
have lost faith in in institutions in
general so these people have lost FAI in
the government they have lost faith in
NASA and Isa don't even mention the IPCC
they have created this small community
where they belong a community wherely
they are relevant they play a role and
people listen to them and they also feel
really threatened by um the lifestyle
changes we keep mentioning what I also
understood is that these people no
matter what I would bring on the table
no matter what argument what data
reports publication they would
absolutely not care now I think that
there's no point trying to waste time
trying to bring these people back unless
the these people are decision makers
unless these people have a really big
role to play and can really change
everything the first thing they're going
to attack you on is your your own carbon
footprint and I get messages like this
everyday on social media we all want to
do the field work believe me I'm the
first one who is always keen to take a
plane to to do the field work wherever
it's taking place but we really need to
think hard about this is there someone
else in this area who can do the field
work instead of me and in the Arctic for
example we're working more and more with
indigenous communities who can do the
field work on your behalf the tremendous
indigenous experts who are fantastic at
the research at following protocols that
I've been co-developed with them um so
we really need to think long and hard in
advance before you find yourself in the
field about how we can reduce the carbon
footprint of research if you want to be
the person telling the policy makers
that we need to be 1.5 compatible your
research needs to to be 1. compatible as
great well thank you guys
[Musique]
happy
mon
glacier voilà ce que tu es
devenu des éclats de glace partout que
tu laisses dans l'océan glacial
[Musique]
Arctique regarde-moi
ça
[Musique]
éparpillé à droite à gauche prè au piège
dans la
banquise le reste de ton
[Musique]
corps icebergs ne sont plus du tout
connectés à
[Musique]
toi dès que l'été sera
venu ils vont fondre attaqués par le
soleil par les
températures d'ici quelques mois il n'y
aura plus rien à cet
[Musique]
endroit
tout cet univers blanc
[Musique]
gigantesque se fait attaquer de toutes
part
aujourd'hui pourtant ça fait longtemps
que tu es là si
longtemps que tu façonnes ce
paysage que tu amènes ton eau dans
l'océan
Arctique c'est aussi riche qui fertilise
les fiordes et l'océan tout
[Musique]
autour
c'est fou de se sentir comme à la maison
dans un environnement
pareil alors que tout est froid tout est
blanc tout est
glacé
mais entouré par tes icebergs c'est là
où je me sens
[Musique]
bien il a quelque chose de magique
ici
quelque chose
[Musique]
d'indescriptible c'est jamais pareil il
y a toujours quelque chose qui s'y
passe que ce soit le vent qui caresse
ses dunes de
neige ces iceberg qui se
décroche pour être pris au pied devant
la
[Musique]
banquise les sons le manque
d'odeur le froid qui nous paralyse mais
qui aussi nous REM met bien les idées en
[Musique]
place
c'est vraiment un des environnements les
plus
puissants un des environnements les plus
mortels
[Musique]
aussi
je demande si tu te rends compte que
chaque iceberg qui se décroche de toi a
les conséquences partout ailleurs sur
[Musique]
terre chaque graine chaque bloc de glace
que tu
[Musique]
perds affecte des milliers voir des
millions de personnes bien au-delà de
l'Arctique
[Musique]
est-ce que tu sais aussi que ton eau
elle permet à des millions voir
carrément des milliards de
personnes de boire d'avoir une
agriculture de produire de
l'hydroélectricité aujourd'hui pour te
remercier on est carrément en train de
te faire
disparaître
[Musique]
je crois qu'on a vraiment rien
compris on a tellement besoin de
[Musique]
toi de ton eau de ta couleur de ta
glace
[Musique]
si tu pouvais parler je me demande ce
que tu nous
dirais je me demande si tu nous
demanderais de nous battre pour
toi juste d'accepter les choses telles
qu'elles
[Musique]
sont je me demande si tu souffres si tu
ressens ce qui se
passe alors qu'aujourd'hui regarde toi
tes entrailles complètement
exposées deses crevasses qui te
traversent
[Musique]
j'ai bien conscience
que quand je te regarde aujourd'hui ben
je sais plus jamais je te reverrai aussi
gros aussi
beau aussi
majestueux qu'année après année tu ne
fais que reculer tu ne fais que
partir
c'est vraiment une mort à petit feu
c'est une agonie qui continue et qui
n'en finit
pas moi c'est impossible d'imaginer ces
paysages sans
toi sans toi qui les couronn sans toi
qui les
domine je te vois vraiment
comme un sage comme un
ancêtre comme celui qui a toujours été
là quoi qu'il arrive moi je te
regarde et j'aimeris que tu
[Musique]
tiennes
et hop sur la
plage sur la plage de Advent fiordan qui
est le fiord qui est directement
connecté à à la capitale du svalbar
longue
herbienne et là on est début
mai et comme vous pouvez le voir mais il
y a pas du tout du tout de banquis dans
le
fiord et ce fiord en fait est connecté à
un fiord encore plus grand qui est juste
ici sur la droite qui s'appelle is
fordon alors cette année ça a été super
compliqué pour la banquise en fait ça
fait des mois ici que les scientifiques
de unersité
prévoit que ça va être presque un point
de N retour pour les fiordes ici
auvalbarn dès le mois de novembre il
nous annonçait qu'en fait que la
température de l'eau était beaucoup
beaucoup trop chaude alors là je suis
sûr si je mets les doigts dedans ça va
pas être à 20°g
elle est quand même bien
fraîche mais ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est fiord en fait ils reçoivent de
l'eau qui vient du girl
stream et cette eau malheureusement plus
en plus chaude donc on a de l'eau qui
est beaucoup trop chaude ici
auvalbard dans ce fiord là en
particulier pour que la banquise se
forme c'est fou de voir que tout est lié
que la perte de cette banquise au nord
et ben elle impacte directement notre
population nos écosystèmes notre
économie beaucoup plus au sud en Europe
et en
France donc ça dépend vraiment que de
nous ce qu'on veut faire de cette
banquise chaque chaque tonne d'énergie
ile que l'on brûle que soit du gaz
naturel du pétrole ou du charbon ben
tout ça ça participe activement à la
disparition de la banquise donc très
clairement l'avenir de la banquise il
est entre nos mains et notre avenir est
directement lié à celui de la banquise
donc son avenir et notre avenir ne tient
plus qu'à nous
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ce qu'on est en train de voir là c'est
un énorme méandre qui a été créé par
l'eau au contact de la glace et on a du
mal à imaginer à quel point cette glace
elle peut complètement changer le
comportement du glacier d'avoir de l'eau
liquide ici déjà ça réchauffe le glacier
de l'intérieur et cette eau au bout d'un
moment elle arrive toujours à trouver le
moyen d'aller à la base du glacier et
lorsquelle arrive à la base du glacier
elle peut lubrifier le mouvement du
glacier sur un socle rocheux et en
accélérer le mouvement donc d'étudier
ces ces cavernes de glace ces
cathédrales de glace c'est ultra
important pour comprendre l'interaction
entre l'eau et la glace et la dynamique
du
[Musique]
glacier
ici on voit un truc qui est assez rare
en fait dans ce genre de glacier qui a
l'air complètement statique qui bouge
plus du tout aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
c'est l'indication que il y a un sacré
petit bout de temps probablement il y a
100 150 ans le glacier était au
contraire ultra actif ultra dynamique et
là on voit bien la différence dans la
couleur de la glace de part et d'autres
de cet endroit très sombre on a de la
glace de glacier normale alors c'est
quoi de la glace GL normale en fait
c'est tout simplement de la glace qui
est remplie de petite bulles d'air qui
s'est créé par l'accumulation de neige
sur des dizaines voir des centaines
d'années et ça on s'attend à voir ça
dans dans tous les glaciers c'est
complètement normal et tout d'un coup on
a cette veine ici où on a certes de la
glace mais on voit qu'elle est
complètement transparente et qu'il y a
plus une seule bulle d'air à l'intérieur
ce qui est assez fou et de part et
d'autrre de cette zone toute noire on a
des sédiments et en fait ce qu'on est en
train de regarder ici c'est une ancienne
crevace une ancienne fracture qui s'est
formée à un moment où le glacier était
hyper actif hyper actif dans le sens où
le glacier bougeait très vite à l'époque
le glacier s'étirait dans tous les sens
ça formait ces fameux craques ces
fameuses fractures et ce qu'on voit
aussi donc c'est cette zone sans Bull
d'ire qui est faite de glace mais pas de
glace de glacier cette fois-ci c'est
tout simplement de l'eau qui a dû
remplir ce craque à la fin de la période
de dynamique de la glace et ce qui est
génial c'est que cette énorme fracture
on la retrouve tout du long donc on voit
que la fracture continue vraiment de
part et d'autrre ici du tunnel et elle
continue et ça si on avait pas ça ben on
aurait vraiment du mal à reconstruire
l'histoire du glacier donc ça nous
permet de de comprendre que finalement
les glaciers peuvent changer très vite
de
comportement
si on était venu ici il y a 1 an le sol
de la grotte de glace il serait juste
ici ce qu'on a ici c'est l'ancien sol
sur lesquel les gens marchaient au
printemps de l'année dernière ce qui se
passe c'est que l'eau de fondte elle
creuse ces galeries qui sont
monumentales ces cagnones en fait dans
le glacier
et l'eau est vraiment capable de de
couper dans la glace comme dans du
beurre c'est vraiment ultra puissant
quoi on se retrouve avec des canyons
gigantesques comme celui qu'on a
audessus de notre tête et là maintenant
on doit avoir bien 20 30 m de glace et
ce qui se passe c'est que ce
canyon le glacier en fait il faut
comprendre qu'il essaie toujours de le
refermer donc pendant l'hiver lorsqu'il
y a plus du tout d'eau qui va continuer
à creuser lorsquil y a plus rien en fait
qui maintient ses cnones ouverts et ben
la glace naturellement de glacier va
essayer de boucher tous ces trous la
glace elle est elle a l'air dure comme
ça mais elle est quand même un petit peu
visqueuse et ainsi on trouve ces
canyonses qui petit à petit vont se
refermer symphonie pour un
glacier
[Musique]
ce glacier c'est de loin un des glaciers
que je connais le plus sur terre J a
passé mais des jours des semaines des
mois à mesurer sa taille à mesurer à
quelle vitesse ce glacier réagit au
dérèglement climatiques et en revenant
ici aujourd'hui que je remarque déjà
rien qu'en regardant le front du glacier
là où on est à quel point il a reculé
ces dernières années c'est un glacier
qui s'est complètement métamorphosé en
réagissant Aug ement climatique il faut
dire qu'ici au zvalbarne on est à
l'endroit sur terre qui se réchauffe le
plus vite aujourd'hui on mesure que le
svalbar se réchauffe 6 à 7 fois plus
vite que le reste de la
planète je pense que le petit oiseau qui
est dans la falaise est d'accord avec
moi les changements qu'on observe ici
sont juste hallucinants ce glacier là
c'est ce qu'on appelle un petit glacier
voilà il fait 45 km de long mais c'est
un GL parmi les 200000 glaciers dans le
monde et on sait qu'aujourd'hui tous ces
glaciers réacissent ce dérèglement
climatique et une des conséquence de
leur perte de glace de leur perte de
volume c'est notamment l'élévation du
niveau des océans même si tu as un
glacier ici auvalbn qui perd de la glace
ben cette glace elle va faire augmenter
le niveau des océans partout sur terre
et on sait que tous les océans sont
connectés donc que l'on habite dans les
Philippines que l'on habite à Miami ou
que l'on habite au Havre et ben on
remarque déjà aujourd'hui que le niveau
des océans augmente et que c
augmentation et c'est ça qui est
vraiment terrible s'accélère aujourd'hui
on est en train de suivre le pire
scénario possible au niveau du
dérèglement climatique et toute cette
glace on sait que si elle fondait
aujourd'hui elle pourrait augmenter le
niveau des océans de 65 m et sur terre
entre juste entre 0 et 10 m d'altitude
il y a 7 millions de personnes et c'est
vraiment ces espaces littorau c'est des
espaces économiques qui sont extrêmement
riches c'est là où il y a le plus de
croissance c'est là aussi où il y a le
plus de croissance au niveau des
populations et on sait que ces
populations si ça continue comme ça elle
commence déjà à se déplacer mais il y
aura des déplacements de plus en plus
importants qui vont toucher non pas que
ces populations là mais tous les autres
territoires sur terre puisque ces
populations là faudra bien qu'elles
aillent quelque part ces activités
économiques faudra bien qu'elles se
déplacent et donc que l'on habite au
valbard ou pas on va tous être touché
par la fonte de ces glaciers et par
l'augmentation du niveau des
[Musique]
océans je travaille pour AMAP Artic
monitoring assessment program qui est un
des groupes de travail du Conseil de
l'Arctique et on a un rôle vraiment clé
dans la transmission des connaissances
scientifique en fait on est
l'intermédiaire entre les scientifiques
le monde académique et les gouvernements
c'est les gouvernements qui nous
approche avec une liste de questions et
c'est à nous d'organiser le travail
scientifique pour pouvoir répondre à ces
questions donc nous non seulement alors
produit des connaissances mais aussi ce
qui est vraiment très très important
c'est qu'on produit des recommandations
après une fois qu'on qu'on partage cette
sciance avec les gouvernements nous ce
qu'on souhaite voir évidemment et ce que
le reste de la planète souhaite voir
aussi ce sont des réactions des
décisions prises le plus rapidement
possible et on voit qu'il y a certains
sujets où les gouvernements réagissent
très très vite notamment au niveau de
l'article tout ce qui touche la santé
humaine à tout ce qui touche la
dégradation des écosystèmes les pays
sont en train de réagir très vite et de
mettre en place vraiment des des
solutions très
concrètes pour leur population qui
habite au nord du cercle polaire il y a
d'autres sujets qui sont super touchy où
là ça avance beaucoup moins vite c'est
tout ce qui touche aux énergies fossiles
parce que pour l'instant c'est clair que
l'Arctique est une des dernières régions
où il y a encore énormément d'énergie
fossile que ce soit ici du charbon hos
valbard il il y a du charbon de partout
euh du gaz et du pétrole il y a beaucoup
de terres rares minerais rares au niveau
du Groenland notamment et là on se rend
compte que ma malheureusement comme
partout ailleurs sur terre ça n'avance
pas assez vite quitte au niveau de la
Norvège notamment à ouvrir de plus en
plus de champs de
[Musique]
pétrole
c'est quoi
oh là là c'est c'est ma plus grande
histoire d'amour je crois c'est glacier
c'est mes ex qui vont pas êre très
contents d'entendre ça mais mais pour
moi c'est c'est c'est c'est tout mon
être quoi et habité par ces glaciers et
c'est
vraiment pour moi c'est ouais c'est
toute ma vie quoi je vois pas comment
com je peux me désolidariser me détacher
de ces environnements là et pour moi
c'est extrêmement important aussi de
faire en sorte que ce soit pas que ma
glace mais que ce soit la glace de tout
le monde quoi c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire tous les jours c'est de faire en
sorte que toutes les personnes
auxquelles je m'adresse B elles aussi
prennent un petit bout de cette glace et
comprennent à quel point cette glace
elle est majestueuse à quel point c'est
magique qu quand tu regardes des pays
visage pareil mais surtout à quel point
cette glace elle est importante et que
aujourd'hui chaque mètre cube de glace
qui disparaît est en train de tous nous
impacter et d'impacter nos enfants leurs
enfants et cetera et cetera sur des
générations entières et pour moi
d'arriver à partager ce message ça passe
avant tout par les émotions quoi au-delà
des connaissances scientifique il faut
que ça passe par le cœur et c'est ce que
j'espère que les personnes qui garderont
en tout cas ces documentaires là
comprendront à quel point bah on a de la
chance quoi on a c'est un privilège pour
nous encore aujourd'hui d'avoir des
glacés sur terre et qu'il faut tous
ensemble tout faire pour les préserver
le plus longtemps
possible
ah c'est trop beau la pierre